Around 5.5 thousand years ago,
the Botai people in Northern Kazakhstan
began riding and milking horses.
This was the beginning of horse domestication,
which allowed humans to travel much faster,
connect to vast territories,
and develop advanced warfare.
Since then, horse domestication
has transformed civilization,
but how exactly has it transformed the horse?
Recently, researchers sequenced
the genomes of ancient horses,
from 4.1 to 2.3 thousand years old.
13 samples come from
the royal burial sites of Scythians,
nomads who ruled much of Central Asia
during the Iron Age.
The Berel site is a rare snapshot of a horse population.
11 samples--all from the same generation.
Sacrificed the same day as part of a funeral ritual,
and almost perfectly preserved in permafrost.
These samples tell us a lot about Scythians
and their horses.
First, the genomes show that the horses in their herds
had a variety of coat-colors.
Scythian horses carried
diverse mutations relating to:
Some of them had gene variants found in today’s
fastest racing horses while others had gene variants
associated with stamina.
Researchers found 121 genes selected by Scythians,
including a large number involved in the development
of the legs of horses.
It seems Scythian breeders selected for strong legs.
Examination of the bones from the burial site
and other Scythian remains confirm this finding.
By comparing ancient genomes
with present day genomes,
researches came away with new insights
on horse domestication
and animal domestication in general.
Scythian horses had a variety of y-chromosomes,
which means male lineages in the first 3 thousand years
of domestication were diverse.
Modern samples however show that breeders seemed
to use less and less of a variety of males,
up to the point that today’s horses all carry
virtually the same y-chromosome.
This tells us that the horse population has collapsed
within the last 2300 years.
which resulted in a reduction
of horse genetic diversity at the whole genome scale.
During this same time period,
breeding practices must have lead to
the introduction of harmful mutations,
because modern horses show
an abundance of these mutations
while Scythian horses don't.
Looking at the changes in horse genomes
also gives support for a domestication hypothesis
involving neural crest cells.
Because these cells develop into many
different tissues and cell lineages,
changes in them might explain
why many domestic animals share
a group of traits like floppy ears and various coat colors.
So studying the genomes of Scythian horses
is starting to bring these ancient animals to life,
but it’ll take make many more samples
from all along the timeline and across the globe
to tell the whole story of horse domestication.